I BB can 11 winner how are you feeling
right now I'm feeling a lot of things uh
this is still a surreal moment I can't
believe that I actually was able to push
through everything that was thrown at me
during this game and come out the winner
but I am proud of myself obviously and
whatever I did worked so I'm here and
I'm super happy and I couldn't be more
happy than I am currently on this moment
I love that I love that well listen we
had the opportunity to see your mama in
the audience yes yes she was like
emotional that is my heart and soul my
mom that's who kept me in the game and I
had a had a rough moment where I was
considering leaving and the letter that
I had received from her was the pivotal
moment to keep me in the game to keep
pushing so amazing that is my heart and
soul for sure amazing well wait let's
talk about that moment for
because I mean
do you have any feelings now that you've
won BB can
the whole idea of even considering
self-eviction like walk me through this
how are we reflecting on so I just think
that you know I'm such a loyal person
and the fact that my right hand at the
time got caught in the crossfire of an
unfortunate situation caused me to
consider is this really for me do I want
to keep pushing forward without you know
my guy
um but ultimately speaking like you know
that was unfortunately his journey here
but it wasn't supposed to be mine so I
decided that I still have a lot of game
left in me I have people rooting for me
at home that want to see me continue to
push through so that was ultimately what
kept me here and what can be pushing
through and I'm thankful that I didn't
leave because obviously this wouldn't be
the case if I did absolutely absolutely
letter gate was like a thing it was a
huge thing man we were like just dropped
yeah yeah you weren't there for that I
wasn't not there for that do you wish
you were there for that I wish I was
there for the sole purpose of the
entertainment however it was probably
not it was probably best I was not there
because I probably would have been
canceled if I got involved with it the
things I may or may not have said to
Koozie in that moment to defend my guys
act to be fair so it's probably best I
wasn't there so I got to see the
aftermath afterwards but I'm happy with
how it turned out all right well listen
what do you think this win means to you
and your family yeah so be winning I
more so wanted people coming from the
situation and the environments that I do
to be able to see someone who looks like
them who talks at them who dresses like
them in this position you know I didn't
care if I actually won first place for a
second I just wanted to be on that stage
beside somebody who I could respect so
that at the end of the day I know that
I'm reaching the demographical people
that need to be represented so I'm here
to represent for people who like I said
come from the situations that I do and I
think I accomplish that amazing amazing
well we gotta talk about a little
showmance you had in that house very
chaotic you know like what is this final
two yeah the show is this is like this
history this is this is me German this
is huge yeah so tell me is this show
man's gonna be taken into real life like
I mean it's all real life yeah but I
mean you know what's what's the
Showman's looking like outside of the
house yeah so I mean showmax is inside
this game we obviously live in a bubble
and you know we see each other every
moment of the day so it's very easy to
build something very quickly with
somebody and obviously Claudia and I
connected very quickly we had our rough
moments where we did completely fall off
and then somehow by the grace of the
bbcan guys we were able to Circle back
and finish this game strong together
um so in terms of outside of this game I
am more than open to seeing where it
goes there's no pressure on either side
you know we discussed that so
um whatever happens after this happens
and you know I'm just proud that I got
to stand beside someone who I thought
was the best player in the game next to
me in a final two and she was the one
that brought me there which speaks
volumes to her game so yeah that's
amazing what do you think this said is
about your social game and like how you
were able to interact with everyone like
you talked about being like a lone wolf
yeah right but then look you had eight
one that's crazy votes for you again
what does that say about your social
game honestly I think coming into this I
like I said I had people that I was
working with and unfortunately they got
taken out of the game pretty early so I
had to adapt and I think that playing
the unorthodox game I think people hear
social and like I said they think they
have to be a good talker they have to be
able to be in groups of people but for
me I realized that people didn't want to
be associated with me because that would
probably mean they would end up on the
block with me so I had to play a
different type of social game where I
would isolate people on a one-to-one
basis and make them feel comfortable
enough sharing information with me that
would help further my game so I wasn't
with groups of people all the time but I
was always with individual people you
know picking their brain to see what was
really going on in this game and how I
could leverage that to my benefit right
right okay well listen we also got to
talk about the fact that you are a comp
Beast yes yes yes yes okay you are going
down in like BB can history you have the
most comp wins you really you did this
yes I know that that's a new fun fact I
honestly thought that there was somebody
with more than me but no you see me um
wow that makes me feel even better now
but right yeah W you got more W's crazy
a lot a lot of W's but I just like you
know every time I would hit the Dr after
you know a win it's always just on to
the next one I'm not focused on how many
how many wins I have it's a cool stat to
have but nonetheless if I didn't win the
show it's kind of for nothing right so I
would just focus on what my next step is
you know and if that was to win the next
comp to keep myself safe great if I
needed to throw comp I also threw a
couple comps too so no you didn't I
promise you I think two comps what comps
did you throw step right up for a
purpose because I needed to backdoor Rob
and I needed him to seem like the bigger
threat than I did and I also threw Brita
which was why the whole letter gate
situation was such a big deal because I
threw that to Hope with a certain
understanding but we'll get into details
we figured it out afterwards and
nonetheless I was happy to see him win
something
um win the money as well and then I can
say we were able to come back around and
actually rebuild that relationship so
amazing two comps that I did though but
nonetheless I still have the record news
to me but yes I'm happy about that glad
to bless you with that I know thank you
appreciate it I mean where do you find
the strength to kind of like keep going
keep winning these things and like you
said just keep focused on the next and
the next and the next where do you where
do you dig that out of yeah so I think
that looking back at my time here in the
BB can you know manner uh it's very
relatable to my life or that I feel is
available to my life outside of here
where it's always the odd stats against
me and I always need to figure out a way
to just figure it out you know I'm not
always going to have the cards in my
favor but at the end of the day my
success or my failure depends on me so I
need to just find a way to dig deep and
keep pushing through whatever challenges
are ahead of me absolutely all right
well you know I gotta ask you what are
you doing with that hundred thousand
dollars well I'm gonna have a talk with
my mom first to see you know if she
needs any help I definitely want to do
some charity work I do charity work
already um but I want to get back to my
Elementary School my middle school
um however I can help the people around
me that's my main focus right now so
that's what I'm doing with it yeah
wonderful so how do you feel about the
jury questions were there any that
surprised you I don't think any of them
surprised me I kind of expected Johnny
to quit question beyond my Integrity in
the game specifically because of my move
against Rob which was his right hand in
the game and I completely understood
that
um and in terms of me explaining my
social game which like I said people did
not see because it was so unorthodox I
also expected that so I was pretty
prepared for whatever the joy wasn't
asked me and none of the questions that
were asked really caught me off guard
okay all right you seem prepared you
were out here ready clearly I'm always
ready for whatever storm all right well
congratulations thank you very much
absolutely absolutely killed it thank
you guys so much thank you